ich rufe dir nochmal an sie kann ich
verschwunden sein programm fand sie
zuletzt gesehen
ich habe frau schäfer tier gebracht
mailbox ruf mich bitte sofort zurück in
der das ab herbst und dann warum ist aus
dem büro gering
vielleicht ist hier nur frische luft
schnappen
ich finde das halten wir alle mal
vielleicht weißt du ja wo sie steckt ein
problem und wollte nicht mit mir darüber
sprechen
deine unterredung heute morgen zufällig
was damit zu tun weil wir
zusammenarbeiten
außerdem war ich die ganze zeit
unterwegs ich hatte auch eine
auseinandersetzung mit ihr macht mich
das verdächtig du könntest auch der
grund sein warum sie ihre ruhe haben
will das ist nicht wahr es reicht ich
will es wissen
so ist ich ins krankenhaus na da muss
etwas wissen so hat es ihn niemals
allein hier sitzen müssen
ich weiß das ist vielleicht nicht der
richtige zeitpunkt aber bevor wir uns
alle noch mehr aufregen wir sollten ruhe
bewahren
franziska wenn wir weiterhin unsere
disposition arbeiten ja du hast recht
das ist eine gute idee
so wird sich schon melden sie
schließlich als genug würden sie bitte
in georgia das büro verordnung willst du
nicht vielleicht mit markt zu tun dass
wohnung vor vielleicht ist er zu hause
gute idee ich muss nach außen danke
lukas ist torsten otte
sie geht bei der kälte nicht ohne jacke
nach hause komisch ihre tasche ist auch
noch da halt geben sie mir mal bitte den
ort nach von graf
ach und ich denke wir sollten die band
den ganzen tag buchen
ich möchte an diesem tag einfach
flexibel bleiben hörst du mir überhaupt
zu die band den ganzen tag buchen
ich hoffe dass ich wenigstens beruflich
highlights dieses projekt karma möchtest
du denn noch keine sorgen
wie bitte gedankt wurde doch keine
sorgen machen
du hast dich hin gesagt woher kennst du
meinen namen
du kannst die sporthilfe ich komme
gleich bärbel
wer von irgendwas bekannt vor dass seine
rechnung von edelweiß technikshow tor
doch noch gesucht warum stellt in
unseren akten er will uns nur helfen reg
dich nicht auf lukas was geht hier vor
was